let me quickly say that I've been a fan  of the Jerry podcast since first started  10 years ago  Joe's open-mindedness and just genuine  curiosity it was a breath of fresh air  especially to me as a scientist but in  general as a thinking person he inspired  me to be a better and especially kinder  human being so it was surreal for me to  be on there a couple of times last year  and I'll be on there again a third time  on February 3rd it feels like I'm  Forrest Gump somehow finding myself  shaking hands with John F Kennedy anyway  I also enjoy playing guitar and I  thought I play the intro steam plus a  bit more to say thank you for the ten  years of Jerry as a wise man once said  train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night  all day  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you